disparition tragique de pierre bérégovoy
l'ancien premier ministre est mort cet
après midi à nevers après s'être tiré
une balle dans la tête
1er mai sanglant au sri-lanka où le
président meurt dans un attentat à la
bombe à moscou affrontement très sérieux
entre la police et des manifestants
nostalgiques du communisme à athènes
ouverture ce soir d'une conférence
réunissant une nouvelle fois tous les
belligérants de l'ex yougoslavie
lord howell nos médiateurs se déclarent
plutôt optimiste le président américain
clinton vient d'annoncer qu'il avait
décidé des mesures nouvelles pour faire
plier les serbes y compris at il dit des
mesures militaires
madame monsieur bonsoir pierre bérégovoy
est mort en fin d'après-midi après
s'être tiré une balle dans la tête à
nevers la ville dont il est maire
les circonstances de ce drame sont
encore mal connues selon certains
témoignages il aurait demandé à son
chauffeur de le conduire sur les berges
d'un canal où il aurait mis fin à ses
jours avec l' arme de service de son
garde du corps confirmation de la
gendarmerie de nevers à quel endroit il
commune de faire moins qu est la
jonction
la berd verte comme une touchante de
verre est ce que le premier ministre
s'est suicidé avec larmes de son garde
du corps
oui comment expliquez-vous ce geste vous
ne rêvez pas alors qu'elle est en cours
alors là je ne peux rien vous dire pour
le moment auquel rien ne laissait
présager ce geste ce matin pierre
bérégovoy avait reçu tous les
syndicalistes de nevers la mairie comme
il le faisait chaque 1er mai je vous
propose de revoir maintenant les
dernières apparitions publiques de
l'ancien premier ministre en compagnie
de nathalie saint cricq
on le savait dépressif ces derniers
jours pierre bérégovoy s'est suicidé
aujourd'hui s'est tiré une balle dans la
tête
il est mort peu après son transfert à
l'hôpital de nevers fidèle de françois
mitterrand
âgé de 66 ans pierre deyries govou était
comme l'on dit un autodidacte
c'est après la résistance en 1946 qu'il
adhère à la et ses filles où il gravit
peu à peu tous les échelons et se
retrouve en 1981 secrétaire général de
la présidence avant d'obtenir en 80 de
son premier portefeuille ministériel
avril 92
il devient premier ministre une
consécration en succédant à edith
cresson
il sera le dernier premier ministre
socialiste de françois mitterrand
on le savait profondément touché par
l'échec de la gauche aux dernières
législatives
un échec qu'il jugeait injuste et
injustifiée on le savait atteint par ce
qui était devenu la sphère du prêt il
avait obtenu un prêt sans intérêt de
l'homme d'affaires roger patrice pelât
il s'était senti blessé dans son honneur
réélu député il y à un mois au milieu
d'une petite poignée de députés
socialistes il restait très discret très
affecté par la défaite après presque 50
années de militantisme socialiste
presque 50 années au service du parti
nathalie saint cricq vient de le
rappeler pierre bérégovoy avait été très
affecté par cette affaire de prêts
immobiliers accordés par roger patrice
pelât je vous propose de réécouter ce
que déclarait l'ancien premier ministre
à ce sujet c'était au mois de février
dernier j'ai reçu d'écho j'espère qu'ils
ne marqueront pas
je voulais déjà dire plusieurs reprises
quand on a
sentiment d'avoir agi en conscience
on ne peut pas être
bousculé par la cad et véronique auger
vous venez de publier un livre consacré
en partie à pierre bérégovoy vous l'avez
beaucoup rencontrés pour les besoins de
ce livre vous disiez tout à l'heure
peut-être est simplement une réaction
d'honneur
je suis sûr que c'est une réaction
d'honneur à la fois parce que
effectivement le l'histoire du prêt que
lui avait fait cet homme d'affaires
proche de monsieur mitterrand prêt sans
intérêt qui avait en provoquer pas mal
de polémiques
elle avait beaucoup touché et puis aussi
parce qu'il a fondé toute sa carrière
sur l'honneur et la rigueur et qu' il se
trouve que lundi il y a le rapport sur
tous les comptes publics qui va être
rendue et que il est évident que sa
gestion va être fortement mise en cause
notamment pendant qu'il a été premier
ministre et ça je crois que ce sont des
choses qui ne supporte pas il faut
rappeler rapidement que qu'il était
d'une origine très modeste et qu'il
avait une carrière politique
particulièrement longue
oui il a commencé tout de suite au parti
socialiste et ce qu'il a le plus frappé
c'est qu'il a été longtemps le
conseiller social de pierre
mendès-france et ça il a beaucoup
beaucoup travaillé avec lui ce qui est
quand même synonyme de rigueur et
d'honneur puis il a beaucoup travaillé
avec françois mitterrand il a gravi
petit à petit tous les échelons et à
chaque fois qu'il a gravi un autre
échelon à chaque fois il nous disait
c'est parce que j'ai réduit le déficit
de la sécurité sociale en laye devenu
ministre des finances et puis là il a
bien marché est bon en dessin me disais
je savais que mon mitterrand me
nommerait premier ministre quand
ce serait très très difficile et c'est
ce qui s'est passé j'ai donc beaucoup
discuté avec lui pour le besoin de se
livrer ce que vous avez évoqué un jour
l'idée de suicide ce genre de choses
non jamais jamais parce que il se trouve
que à l'époque quand j'ai rencontré
était premier ministre il se battait
beaucoup et que bon à l'époque il était
effectivement atteint par l'histoire du
prêt mais toutes ces histoires de
déficit on a un petit peu le sentiment
que toute la partie budgétaire sur
laquelle il avait fondé toute sa
carrière une haie de gauche 1 on disait
toute cette partie budgétaire lui a
échappé quand il était premier ministre
c'était monsieur charasse qui était à la
tête du budget et monsieur sapin à la
tête des finances
et puis tout ce qu'il avait dit la
rigueur pas de déficit et s'est petit à
petit tout et tout est parti et
peut-être n'at-il pas tout maîtriser et
peut-être aujourd'hui
n'at-il pas supporté que l'on puisse le
mettre en cause lui qui était
franchement c'est vrai que quelqu'un de
rigoureux
merci véronique que pour ce premier
témoignage ou compose maintenant de
découvrir le reportage de mon confrère
hervé charbonnier de france 3 10
joliette en direct de dijon oui n'avons
malheureusement pas encore d'image notre
équipe est sur place mais tout ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que que nous vert
est sous le choc actuellement pierre
bérégovoy je vous le rappelle a été
découvert à 18h15 ce soir près du canal
du nivernais
il s'était tiré une balle dans la tête
avec larmes de son garde du corps à
l'insu de ce dernier auparavant il avait
reçu les syndicalistes dans sa mairie
avant avant de faire cette dernière
promenade
il a été rapidement transporté au samu
de nevers où sa mort a malheureusement
été constaté
il était très doux très déprimée vous
l'avez dit depuis une dizaine de jours
malgré son discours de satisfasse de
satisfaction qu'il avait prononcé le
soir même de sa réélection à la
députation à nevers il avait aussi
quitté récemment le conseil général de
la nièvre pour se consacrer à sa mairie
et à son mandat de député
merci beaucoup pour ces précisions je
vous signale que demain l'heure de
vérité à midi sur france 2 sera bien sûr
entièrement consacré à pierre bérégovoy
qui vient donc de disparaître
bien sûr si nous avons d'autres
réactions au cours de ce journal bien
évidemment nous vous les diffuseront le
reste de l'actualité avec bien sûr les
défilés du 1er mai en france
les syndicats ont fêté ce produit
revin très une nouvelle fois en ordre
dispersé sur fond d'aggravation du
chômage et d'annonce la semaine
prochaine de mesures qualifiées d'
impopulaire seule la cgt a respecté la
tradition du défilé dans les rues de
paris avec jean pierre métivier et
michel levasseur scandons sous la pluie
au moins sur le pavé de paris
cela avait le goût des premiers mais
d'antan la couleur les mêmes certitudes
et la forêt de parapluies et le nombre
près de quarante mille personnes la
police en comptait 15 le slogan
solidarité hausse des salaires et
critique des projets du gouvernement
non seulement il ne sort pas des
sentiers battus mais mais il s'enfonce
au contraire dans les ornières qui
jusqu'à maintenant ont cherché à peser
sur les conditions de vie des salariés
ont conduit à la situation que l'on
connaît dans le domaine de l'emploi et
aboutisse à une nouvelle dégradation qui
va conduire à nouveau à des appels à de
nouveaux sacrifices
jusqu'où de l'inattendu aussi des
chômeurs d'ordinaire éparpillés isolés
ils étaient cette fois près d'un millier
au même endroit en avait pas
nous devons apprendre le braille
je manifeste et puis pêle-mêle des
associations antiracistes sos racisme et
même des écologistes du mouvement vert
mais eux on les avait jamais vus lors
des premiers mais d'antan
les mets décentralisée pour la cfdt a
nancy la ville natale de nicole notât
renaud fessaguet et bruno gironde ont
rencontré un militant lorrain de la cfdt
un peu nostalgique des 1er mai
traditionnels après 40 ans du sinn et 35
de syndicalisme jean est né en a connu
des premiers mais des sages des
mouvementée et joyeux où des graves
quand il s'agissait de défendre la
sidérurgie lorraine
aujourd'hui jean est en pré retraite
mais il revient souvent à la
cristallerie daum où il était verrier un
métier qui n'a pas changé depuis des
siècles ce qui a changé c'est la vie
d'entreprise la rentabilité les plans
sociaux la solidarité qui disparaît
comme la classe ouvrière et les premiers
mais de plus en plus désunie souvenir
d'un militant
il y a une vingtaine d'années ont défilé
dans les rues de nancy je le rappelle on
était une bonne escadrille militants ils
prenaient ce cadre il avait rang de
salariés maintenant maleyran qui montait
et puis je me vois encore d'ailleurs
place de la carrière du sel
depuis jean et ses amis doivent
s'habituer à d'autres émotions syndicale
car cette année la cfdt a décidé de ne
pas manifester d'abandonner la
traditionnelle manif bastille république
pour donner la parole à la province en
l'occurrence nancy ici donc pour ce 1er
mai pas de défilé peu de revendication
juste un appel à la fête et à la musique
le dernier défilé où la cdp a participé
aux deux versants de 100 200 personnes
et pour nous ce n'est pas suffisant et
les militants avaient envie qu'on leur
offre autre chose
il a fallu qu'on réfléchisse entre nous
et inventé un nouveau concept
autre innovation cfdt un 1er mai
unitaire non pas avec les syndicats mais
avec les patrons locaux et andré
rossinot ministres du gouvernement
balladur là encore les temps changent
j'espère bien qu'on ne reverra avec des
ministres de droite car ce sont eux qui
sont au gouvernement il nous n'entendons
pas les laisser tranquilles dans les
politiques qui l'ont amené le
syndicalisme existe nous avons des
revendications et des exigences à poser
donc ce n'est que le début
attention donc au delà des apparences la
cfdt a toujours envie d'être un cactus
pour de nouveau gouvernement
force ouvrière quant à elle organisé un
débat l'arche de la défense près de
paris entre 200 jeunes et des
responsables de cette confédération
c'est désormais une habitude le front
national profite du 1er mai pour
célébrer jeanne d'arc avec huit jours
d'avancé sur le calendrier
l'occasion aujourd'hui pour jean marie
le pen d'afficher la volonté de son
mouvement d'être je cite la seule
opposition honorable face aux nouvelles
demandes
la dure qualifiait de centre gauche
reportage jean baptiste près dali crise
tombe jean marie le pen peut bien
cherché parmi la foule des militants du
front national depuis le 28 mars plus
moyen d'y trouver un député il y à bien
jeanne d'arc pour ouvrir le cortège
il y à bien la famille le pen au grand
complet comme chaque 1er mai il y à même
les conseillers régionaux du mouvement
sein d'une écharpe mais il n'ya plus de
représentants élus à l'assemblée
du coup pour son défilé le fonds
national donne sa version corrigée de la
politique dite de la chaise vide
c'est la représentation symbolique que
nous avons voulu donner des députés du
pont national qui devrait aujourd'hui
être à l'assemblée si le mode de scrutin
avaient respecté proportionnellement le
nombre des électeurs français seulement
le scrutin proportionnel n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour alors alternative pour
le front national se présenter comme
seule opposition à la droite au pouvoir
et comme recours éventuels en attendant
95 et l'élection présidentielle même
entourée de ses partisans le temps
risque de paraître bien long à jean
marie le pen à moscou la célébration du
1er mai a dégénéré en violents
affrontements entre policiers
manifestants 150 blessés peut être un
mort du côté des forces de l'ordre les
manifestants étaient des nostalgiques du
régime communiste qui ont tenté en vain
de braver l'interdiction de défiler sur
la place rouge commentaires cet
après-midi de boris elstine c'est une
provocation des opposants communistes
qui ont montré leur vrai visage anti
démocratique
reportage de nos correspondants marcel
trillât jean-françois bernigaud
l'affrontement brutal sur l'avenue
lénine
un camion de manifestants va reculer
délibérément contre le barrage de
véhicules qui bloquent le passage un
policier anti-émeutes de 25 ans a été
coincé entre les deux ce soir son état
est critique
les manifestants vont alors empêché les
policiers de le dégager
c'est le corps à corps un déchaînement
de violence jamais vues encore à moscou
depuis l'effondrement de l'union
soviétique en tout 77 blessés dont
quatre graves parmi les forces de
l'ordre
70 blessés dont un grièvement du côté
des manifestants
un déploiement de force sans précédent
avait d'abord empêché les manifestants
de rejoindre la place rouge au centre
ville puis l'université sur léman lénine
les manifestants étaient un peu plus de
5000 à l'appel des conservateurs
communistes et nationalistes à leur tête
plusieurs accusés du procès des
putschistes rien n'est perdu pour nous
ceux qui sont perdus ce sont les
serviteurs de ce régime vous êtes des
chiens
la rage impuissante des vaincus du
référendum et leurs inévitables slogans
antisémites
le sionisme ne passera pas vive l'amitié
des travailleurs du monde entier
à bas le capital un homme qui veut qu'on
sache qu'il veut en découdre
basi film et qui ne cache pas qu'elle
sorte de régime il souhaite à nouveau
pour la russie ce soir la télévision
russe a longuement montrer la violence
des manifestants sans commentaire puis
le porte parole du président eltsine a
annoncé des poursuites judiciaires
contre les organisateurs de ce qu'il a
appelé une vilenie sanglant la journée
avait pourtant bien commencé avec une
autre manifestation celle des syndicats
autorisé peu à se rassembler place du
manège en plein centre de moscou
ainsi va la russie nouvel emprunt les
larmes et les rênes la violence et les
chansons retour maintenant à
l'information principale de la soirée la
tentative de suicide de pierre bérégovoy
tout à l'heure la préfecture de la
nièvre confirmé officiellement le décès
de l'ancien premier ministre socialiste
décès confirmés également au cabinet du
président de la république à paris selon
la préfecture de la nièvre monsieur
bérégovoy serait dans un état très grave
et le pronostic vital serait réservé
d'après les médecins donc informations
parfaitement contradictoires nous avons
au téléphone jack lang qui nous monsieur
le ministre est ce que vous nous
entendez bonsoir est ce que pierre
bérégovoy que vous connaissez très bien
vous paraissez déprimé ces temps
derniers est ce que cette tragique
nouvelle vous a surpris
d'abord je voudrais vous dire je je suis
bouleversée et je ressens une grande
peine
une immense tristesse et je veux espérer
que ce que vous disiez à l'instant c'est
à dire que l'irréparable ne s'est pas
produit serait confirmée bon mais pierre
bérégovoy depuis un an a mené à la tête
du gouvernement un combat courageux
souvent héroïques et je les ai vus en
effet de près c'est un homme d'honneur
c'est un homme de caractère un homme
courageux qui s'est dépensé sans compter
pour le pays pour son gouvernement et
pour la campagne électorale dit beaucoup
que la sphère du prêt sans intérêt un
beaucoup beaucoup affecté pierre
bérégovoy c'est difficile pour moi de ne
parler à sa place ou à la place de ses
proches
je dirais que les attaques indignes et
déshonorante n'ont pas manqué et celle
d'un homme mais je répète qu'il y avait
qui a beaucoup de caractère et de
courage
mais certains ont voulu porter atteinte
à son honneur d'ailleurs malheureusement
depuis quelques années trop souvent on
joue avec l'honneur des hommes et en
particulier hommes politiques
puis je voudrais que depuis un mois on
ne cesse de tirer à boulet rouge sur
l'action économique et monétaire et
financière qui l'a conduite à la tête du
gouvernement
et comme chacun sait grâce à pierre
bérégovoy
l'économie française a été assainie et
la monnaie le franc pour lequel il s'est
battu jour après jour est devenu la
monnaie la plus forte du monde et à
aucun moment vous entendez à aucun
moment depuis un mois
aucune parole n'a été prononcée pour
rendre hommage à l'action exceptionnelle
qui était la sienne est sans cesse on a
dénigré dénigrer dénigrer at on besoin
lorsqu'on conduit une politique nouvelle
de tirer à boulets rouges contre ces
paires et ses prédécesseurs alors
j'ignore personnellement les les raisons
mais ces temps derniers je me sentais
très proche de lui et je lui ai beaucoup
parlé
je répète c'est un homme très courageux
nomme une grande probité d'une grande
honnêteté et parfois je me mets à sa
place je me disais comme ça doit être
tus
dur pour lui qui a tant fait pour le
pays être à ce point attaqué mis en
cause en particulier pour l'action
exceptionnel qu'il a mené pour
l'économie de la france donc je vous
remercie
cette dernière information qui nous
provient de la préfecture de la nièvre
qui confirme que monsieur bérégovoy est
dans un état très grave et qu'il est
actuellement question de le transporter
dans un hôpital de la région parisienne
probablement le val-de-grâce autre
réaction d'un dirigeant socialiste celle
de jean poperen qui affirme avoir
beaucoup de peine on sait comment il a
été atteint profondément ces derniers
jours dit il décidément pour ceux qui ne
sont pas de l'establishment c'est dur
d'accéder à de hautes responsabilités
politiques
bien sûr au cours de ce journal d'autres
réactions d'autres informations sur
cette nouvelle vous propose déroulé le
reste de l'actualité est bien sûr ce 1er
mai particulièrement sanglant à colombo
puisque la capitale du sri lanka a été
victime d'un terrible attentat le
président a trouvé la mort dans cet
attentat à la bombe probablement une
attaque suicide
cet attentat a fait au moins 17 morts et
60 blessés
véronique taveau image difficile à
soutenir
l'horreur d'un attentats
particulièrement sanglants l'explosion a
eu lieu au moment où anna sting et
premadasa le président du sri lanka
s'exprimait devant les militants de son
parti à l'occasion des fêtes du 1er mai
une attaque suicide selon des témoins un
homme à bicyclette se serait élancé vers
le président un homme transportant sur
lui plusieurs kilos d'explosifs
dix sept personnes au moins ont été
tuées et 60 autres grièvement blessés un
attentat qui s'il n'a pas encore été
revendiqué porte la marque d'un groupe
indépendantiste tamoule
les tigres libérateurs de l'eelam tamoul
le sri-lanka une petite île déchiré
depuis des années par le conflit qui
oppose les deux principales communautés
du pays
les tamouls au nord les cinghalais au
sud un conflit qui a déjà fait dix sept
mille morts
élu à la présidence du pays en 89
ranasinghe premadasa avait promis de
ramener la paix dans l'île peu après son
investiture il avait eu cette phrase ma
tâche maintenant bâtir la paix si
j'échoue les armes parleront mais je
suis sûr de ma victoire 1er mai de
guerre à sarajevo où des tireurs
embusqués les artilleurs n'ont pas chômé
aujourd'hui quatre obus de mortier sont
tombés sur le centre de cette ville
faisant huit morts ou dans la nouvelle
et une vingtaine de blessés sur les
principaux fonds de la bosnie les
accrochages armés se sont multipliés
à quelques heures de l'ouverture à
athènes d'un ultime sommet réunissant
tous les belligérants selon le médiateur
britannique lord owen la paix en bosnie
et je le cite à portée de main tout de
suite le reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux
gérard beau fils françois granier à
l'abri des regards derrière les vitres
teintées de sa voiture officielle voici
le président serbe
l'énigme de cette rencontre d'athènes
dans un cadre idyllique une station
balnéaire habituellement fréquentés par
les touristes fortunés
sous un beau soleil printanier mais
aussi sous très haute surveillance c'est
ici que va peut être se jouer l'avenir
de la bosnie herzégovine tous les
protagonistes du conflit sont présents
les dirigeants de belgrade et les
médiateurs internationaux également il y
a longtemps que vouliez amélie n'avait
pas vécu pareille agitation et une telle
concentration d'observateurs venus du
monde entier
ce qui est sûr c'est que les
négociations de paix sont dans l'impasse
alors que les massacres continuent dans
l'ex yougoslavie et que le parlement
serbe de bosnie s'apprêtent à rejeter de
nouveau les propositions de lord owen et
de cyrus vance
pierre d'achoppement de toutes ces
tractations qui se succèdent sans
aboutir le projet de la mise en place en
bosnie d'un corridor démilitarisé sous
contrôle international soient vos dame
milosevic le président serbe aurait
maintenant quelques divergences de vue
sur la question avec ses alliés
de quoi redonner sans doute espoir à
tous ceux qui oeuvrent pour la paix
l'objet de cette réunion c'est bien sûr
de faire plier les serbes de bosnie et
de la faire accepter le plan de paix 26
wayne ce qu'ils ont toujours refusé
jusqu'à présent
il faut dire que le contexte a changé
tout à fait récemment l'intervention
militaire occidentale se fait de plus en
plus menaçante et le blocus depuis mardi
dernier de la serbie et du monténégro
gêne considérablement l'accès fédération
yougoslave à washington bill clinton a
longuement réuni ses principaux
conseillers en matière de diplomatie de
défense pour étudier l'éventualité d'une
action renforcée contre les serbes de
bosnie sans doute pour le nouveau
président américain la décision la plus
lourde de conséquence depuis son entrée
à la maison blanche en janvier avec nous
en direct de washington sur les pelouse
de la maison blanche notre correspondant
permanent jean marc et loup jean marc
est-ce que vous avez des précisions sur
les mesures nouvelles décidées
aujourd'hui ou annoncées par
l'administration démocrate
eh bien disons que quatre heures de
discussions stratégiques consacrées à la
boss lui ils viennent de se terminer à
l'instant au tour de vis de 20 tonnes et
le secrétaire d'état américain
christopher vient de nous annoncer que
les mesures que les propositions
stratégiques américaines qu'il part dès
ce soir présenté aux européens
comporteront un volet militaire
alors voir une christopher n'a pas bien
sûr voulu nous donner le détail de ces
mesures
elles le feront d'ailleurs l'objet d'une
décision finale du président clinton
qu'après les consultations non seulement
avec les européens mais également avec
les russes et avec le congrès américain
cela dit warren christopher a été très
ferme
il a dit que désormais les serres devez
comprendre que je cite le compte à
rebours a commencé que le temps des
manipulations des manoeuvres dilatoires
est terminé et qu'une simple signature à
athènes sur un bout de papier ne sera
pas suffire si elle n'est pas suivie sur
le terrain d'actes concrets des serbes
autant dire que désormais le temps
presse autre question jean marc que
précisément apparemment les américains
donc ne partage pas franchement
l'optimisme de lord owen sur cette issue
favorable de cette conséquence d'athènes
qui va démarrer ce soir il ya d autres
les américains suivent avec intérêt ce
qui se passe at elle et lyon d'ailleurs
dépêché leur envoyé spécial
l'ambassadeur butler mieux mais pour
autant il n'est pas question pour eux de
se laisser si vous voulez distraire ou
amadouer par des gestes de bonne volonté
serbe
si encore une fois je reprends les mots
du secrétaire d'état ils ne sont pas
suivis
immédiatement par les actes merci jean
marc que vous étiez en direct de
washington nous en saurons plus bien sûr
dans les toutes prochaines heures je
vous propose maintenant de mettre le cap
vers le médoc en gironde où les
chasseurs avaient décidé de braver une
nouvelle fois l'interdiction de la
chasse à la tourterelle cette année les
écologistes n'étaient pas au rendez vous
ni les oiseaux migrateurs
reportage françois privat dans le médoc
chasse et la tourterelle commence
forcément par un passage chez le boucher
guidée en chasse depuis plus de 40 ans
dans un contexte où la tradition est
plus forte que toute interdiction
j ai adoré la montée des possédés place
et les remonter
comme si de rien n'était et nos
détracteurs ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils
voudront on a une tradition qu'on a le
respectera tu voyais aujourd'hui c'est
le 1er mai j'ai entendu deux ou trois
coups de fusil
et puis il s'est toujours y avait pour
le moment on patiente sont pas un bon
bol d'air on s'amuse
d'après on va casser la croûte parce que
vraiment ça creuse depuis 5h30 de haut
niveau
10h30 allain bougrain dubourg n'est pas
venu pas plus que les gendarmes qui
retrouve alors ses amis des pylônes
voisins à loos typiquement médocaine
épilogue habituel et légal d'une partie
de chasse à la tourterelle et voilà
qu'il faut pour être heureux après ça
quand ils te crois comme lui j'ai une
appréciation pour les vous n'aurez pas
la tourterelle nos pigeons nos fils et
nos cas là
comme le dit la chanson mon dieu quel
bonheur d'avoir un mari bricoleur et
pourquoi ne pas mettre la vidéo au
service des sous doués de la perceuse
d'où l'idée d'un confrère michel galy
qui met en vente une série de cassettes
vidéo expliquant précisément aux
amateurs comment s'y prendre reportage
au salon du bricolage à la foire de
paris jean pisier philippe aussi la
famille blaizel vient d'acheter un
logement dans cet immeuble ses finances
étant réduite
le mari jean claude a décidé de faire
lui même certains travaux ainsi la pose
de parquet flottant dans le salon
économie 3000 francs mais avant de se
lancer jean claude se sentait soutenu
ouais comme ça jusqu'à la pente et
ensuite on revient pour la deuxième
rangée en commençant par une 2000 âmes
pour la découpe et là je vous conseille
ne plus taire parce qu'une fille
d'affaires de la sueur avec le cooper
ont passé plusieurs fois par la cour y'a
jamais que trois minutes et demie devant
les lacets corriger facilement les
erreurs au niveau de la coupe
qu'il doit être très franches dans la
cassette j'aurais pas fait la même chose
il faut être un bruit de leur proposer
ce parc est mon corps l'activité
favorite des bricoleurs l'entretien des
meubles vernis au tampon décapage patine
le bois est l'objet de longues caresses
et surtout le chéri de ces dames
j'ai préparé mes réseaux face au jeune
femme je travaille à 90% pour les femmes
c'est elles qui s'en prend au cul et ce
sont elles qui me dit ce sont elles qui
lisent ont fait ça et j'ai vu 10 chez
moi j'agis n'est pas tous amis ou en
tissu est pas une mince affaire
quelqu'un qui vous donnera des conseils
chez vous à la visite très bien
la vidéo au service du bricolage peut
devenir un moyen simple de faire des
économies avec une garantie de qualité
le rêve des bricoleurs ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux 20 millions dans
l'hexagone au championnat d'europe
d'athènes judo rime avec cocorico avec
huit médailles dont 5 en or l'équipe de
france de judo en effet largement dominé
la première journée des finales et ce
n'est pas fini
six français sont encore en course pour
demain pour une médaille dont quatre
pour un titre européen
pascal tous ces bons ce qu'elle aime par
dessus tout c'est ramasser les jambes de
ses adversaires tout en puissance
laëtitia mais n'y en a pas fait de
détail ippon face à la belge ou la vère
bruch et troisième titre européen pour
la reine laetitia victoire symbole de
l'archi domination française dans cette
première journée de championnat d'europe
confirmation également pour stéphane
traîneau en moins de 95 kg histoire de
prouver que ces jeux olympiques ratés ne
sont plus qu'un mauvais souvenir
on attendait aussi pascal cayot en moins
de 86 kg il a choisi de jouer la
tenaille le moldave magot madoff en bleu
ne peut rien faire
une clé de bras qui permet à ta yo de
conserver son titre européen
passons maintenant au petit nouveau de
l'équipe de france alice dubois remporte
la catégorie des moins de 66 kg une
victoire à la décision des arbitres pour
la belle surprise de ces championnats
d'europe
autre surprise dans la série si c'est
possible
le jeune darthial liant dit en blanc
crochète le bras de son adversaire avec
les jambes premier titre pour y andy qui
est encore junior avec le bronze pour
nataline à lupino et catherine fleury
vachon et l'argent de david douillet
cela fait huit médailles sur huit
combattants et ce n'est pas fini
la france peut encore espérer si podium
demain peut-être quatre médailles d'or
supplémentaires toujours des rumeurs
contradictoires après le suicide de
pierre bérégovoy à matignon et l'elysée
confirme la mort de l'ancien premier
ministre socialiste l'hôpital de nevers
affirme au contraire que pierre
bérégovoy est dans le coma je vous
propose d'entendre le témoignage
recueilli tout à l'heure par françois
cornut au téléphone du chirurgien de
garde de cet hôpital de new vert n'est
pas très bien mais n'est pas décédé
bon eh qu'est ce que vous avez constaté
exactement qu'il y aie aie
il ya des blessures par balles grave
dans le crâne ou pas est-ce que vous
pensez que ces jours maintenant sont
réellement en danger ou est ce que vous
pensez pouvoir le sauver et proverbes en
possession d' angers 2e
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire vous
comptez de l'opérer ou pas mais on pense
qu'il ya les rapatriés sur paris le
rapatrier sur le bal sur fun s'organiser
bon donc vous confirmez bien que
monsieur bérégovoy n'est pas mort et
qu'il est il est simplement blessé pour
l'instant pierre bérégovoy avait 66 ans
je vous propose de voir un portrait de
cette personnalité si ni nathalie saint
cricq
l'autodidacte et il en est fier c'est
après la résistance en 1946 qu'il adhère
à la et ses filles où il gravit peu à
peu tous les échelons et se retrouve en
1981 secrétaire général de la présidence
avant d'obtenir en 80 de son premier
portefeuille ministériel avril 92 il
devient premier ministre
une consécration en succédant edith
cresson il sera le dernier premier
ministre socialiste de françois
mitterrand
on le savait profondément touché par
l'échec de la gauche aux dernières
législatives
un échec qu'il jugeait injuste et
injustifiée on le savait atteint par ce
qui était devenu la sphère du prêt il
avait obtenu un prêt sans intérêt de
l'homme d'affaires roger patrice pelât
il s'était senti blessé dans son honneur
réélu député il y à un mois au milieu
d'une petite poignée de députés
socialistes il resté très discret très
affecté par la défaite de la gauche aux
élections
une défaite qu'il avait vécu comme un
échec personnel après presque 50 ans de
militantisme socialiste
il avait commencé dans la vie avec un c
ap d'ajusteur était devenu premier
ministre et le parti
c'était la grande histoire de sa vie
réaction du nouveau porte-parole du
parti socialiste jean glavany une fois
de plus les mises en cause publiques
provoquent des drames jean glavany
affirme que pierre bérégovoy avait été
profondément atteint par sa mise en
cause publique dans une affaire qui
l'avait profondément touchée dans son
honneur
allusion bien sûr à la sphère du prêt de
patrice pelât un rappel avec christophe
thorin c'est pour acheter en 1986 cet
appartement dans le 6e arrondissement de
paris que pierre bérégovoy avait dû
s'endetter
le canard enchaîné avait révélé cette
affaire un prêt d'un million de francs
sans intérêt il y avait été accordée par
roger patrice pelât son ami mais
également l'ami du président mort en
1989 après avoir été inculpé dans la
serpe et chine et l' affaire avait été
découverte par le juge thierry
jean-pierre cet homme en 1992 alors
qu'il enquêtait sur une affaire de
fausses factures dans le bâtiment pierre
bérégovoy s'était toujours défendu
d'avoir été dans l'illégalité en
acceptant ce prêt voici ce qu'il
déclarait le 3 février dernier
sp côté assuré mais pierre bérégovoy
avait été très affecté par cette
histoire qui pour la première fois
ternie c'est son image dans un journal
philippe lefait reviendra bien
évidemment très longuement sur ce drame
dans un instant de la météo avec
nathalie rihouet excellente soirée à
demain 20 heures